el principal objetivo de estas sanciones
es limitar el financiamiento a Rusia
para que frene la invasión a Ucrania
realmente tendrán un impacto negativo
Qué tal Buen día Valentina Pues el
impacto que se busca que se tengan estas
estas medidas en primer lugar es que los
países no occidentalizados es decir los
países no alineados O no aliados de de
occidente pues tengan
un tope para poder limitar los ingresos
financieros a Rusia no tanto así por los
posibles compradores
occidentalizados esto Pues busca impedir
que debido a la dinámica inflacionaria y
a los próximos alzas en en los productos
petrolíferos Premium que si vienen
siendo estos refinados Pues bueno se
busca frenar el un digamos una ganancia
adicional y limitar los recursos dado
que la la Unión Europea y países
occidentalizados sobre todo en Europa
Bueno pues han buscado diversificar su
suministro de productos petrolíferos y
esto Pues también ha provocado una
desaceleración en ingresos rusos lo que
se busca es incrementar la capacidad de
esta desaceleración bueno justamente
usted estaba mencionando algo respecto a
lo que le voy a preguntar que la Unión
Europea frene la importación de diesel
de Rusia que es el combustible que usan
casi la mitad de los autos que circulan
dentro del bloque es viable y cómo se
están reemplazando estas importaciones
ahora este planteamiento que haces es
muy importante dado que es un
planteamiento que nada
económico ya
sabemos han estado diversificando su
suministro desde Estados Unidos desde
medio oriente y desde el norte de África
para obviamente tener una seguridad
energética respecto de lo que tenían en
Rusia obviamente es buscado un poquito
los precios al consumidor sin embargo
pues la la población se ha ido ha ido
asimilando estas medidas y finalmente
esto es una como insisto Y esto es una
medida más más que nada política Más
allá de económica dado que ya se tienen
más de ocho meses con este tipo de
medidas de restricción de productos
rusos esto lo único que hace es
reafirmar las medidas que se han llevado
a cabo en los últimos meses bueno
hablando un poco más a gran escala Qué
impacto en el mercado mundial puede
tener estas nuevas medidas hay quienes
temen un alza de precios y más presiones
inflacionarias
Bueno finalmente
sí existe una ambivalencia en las
en las posibles en los posibles efectos
en con todos mis colegas alrededor del
mundo sin embargo todos coincidimos en
que esto sí va a causar un impacto
bastante bastante fuerte sobre todo a
nivel de comercio exterior y comercio
global de Rusia con países no alineados
por ejemplo economías como India o como
o como China o como el llano Irak que
son aliados naturales de Rusia y que han
estado de alguna manera adquiriendo
estos productos finalmente ellos lo van
a ver como una un costo de oportunidad
quizás ahí por un tema de volumen existe
esa ambivalencia de este de los efectos
negativos
dado que al incrementar el volumen se
pueden incrementar los este los ingresos
para Rusia sin embargo Pues no va a
estar en el mismo en la misma situación
económica que las petroleras y empresas
occidentales dado que ellos iban a
aprovechando las dinámicas que vamos a
ver para los próximos meses en el
mercado de petróleo y refinados bueno y
Qué reacción Podemos esperar de Rusia
ante la entrada en vigor de las
sanciones
Bueno pues ya hemos visto que Rusia
normalmente lo que hace es condenar
enérgicamente a nivel político estas
estas acciones muy probablemente
continuarán este tipo de
estrategias sobre el suministro de gas
natural ruso a a la Unión Europea quizás
podemos llegar a una a una cancelación
completa del suministro sin embargo Pues
bueno vamos a ver que las los efectos
igual por parte de Rusia van a ser más
que nada económicos y quizás veamos un
recrudecimiento en contra de Ucrania